[Applause]  [Laughter]  there you go Ernie dango  Ernie look la rtu her baby Ernie I'm an  adorable baby  it's glasses off [ __ ] there it is all  right  [Music]  oh you know I read French run over that  way you know what you got it  what are you go oh yeah that's good can  they play now look your baby on the  gangster  this is youngster look old sorry about  that  you want to put the one on there that  the gang is the male and female you see  now we are Elizabeth oh they just pretty  if I'm a baby let me see the baby at the  baby looks the same this is my favorite  wait I think this is my baby  you're looking like Paul Pierce right  there I like that  jack already has a beard let me see what  he look like let me see the baby with  the big  [Music]  all right that's a wrap